لنكن صريحي هذا البلد فرنسا لم يكن
تاريخيا بين الكبار في عالم كره القدم لكن
منذ ربع قرن وحتى الان لم يحقق اي بلد
انجازات كرويه مثل فرنسا اربعه نهائيات في
المونديال وكاسان وهناك رمز كبير لهذا
التحول واسمه زين الدين زيدان الى عام
1998 عندما ربحت فرنسا كاس العالم بقياده
زين الدين او زيزو واقيمه الاحتفالات في
هذه الجاده هذه
تكررت الصوره في العام 2018 وقبل اسابيع
قليله انتظر الفرنسيون انتصارا مماثلا على
هذه الجاده لكن الخساره امام الارجنتين
تحولت بسرعه اعصارا في كره القدم الفرنسيه
والشباكا كبيرا دخل فيه الجميع تقريبا رغم
الخساره في قطر تمت تمديد للمدرب جديد شو
حتى 2026 بينما كانت الترشيحات والتمنيات
تتجه الى تصريحان يختصران الاسماء رئيس
الاتحاد الفرنسي لكره القدم لوالديك غاد
يخرج بتصريح مسلسل عندما سئل عن امكانيه
ذهب زيدان الى البرازيل للتدريب المنتخب
هناك قال لا يحرمني العمر يمكنه الذهاب
الى حيث يريد واقوى ردا اتى من النجم
الجديد الذي قال زيدان هو فرنسا يجب ان لا
نقلل من احترامه الاسطوره بعد كل السنوات
والانجازات
المتحده من الجزائر وسيذكر الجميع هذا
التصريح للمدير السابق لمانشستر يونايتد
سر
اعطيني زيدان وعشوا قطعا من الخشب وسافوز
بدوري الابطال باريس